in 2013 CNN reported that a zoo in luhai
Hanan tried to pass off a large hairy
dog as a lion what is happening in China
I've seen people do that with labber
Doodles a lot yeah a visitor told
Beijing youth daily that when she and
her son approached the cage marked
African lion they they heard it barking
they were greeted not by a
mighty Roar but a
bark that's great why is the lion
barking why is the lion any of you guys
uh in person heard a lion Ro
the you can feel it
right rates your body the furry beast
turned out to be a Tibetan Mas also the
lions like don't show up a lot I've been
to the San Diego Zoo a bunch and they're
never where you want them to be dogs are
way
better dogs will do tricks you can like
get if you throw the frisbee that lion
will go get it that's
right